How do Smoke Detectors Work
At their core, smoke alarms are very simple
devices that need only two functions: a way
of detecting smoke and a way of alerting people
to the problem.
From new technology involving lasers to old
world technology that relies on a lonely individual
sitting in a tower on the side of a mountain
just waiting to see smoke, all do the same
thing in different ways.
The two most commonly used smoke alarms (mainly
because they are inexpensive) are photoelectric
and ionization detector alarms.
The difference between the two lies in how
they detect smoke particles.
Depending on the conditions of the fire, one
type is usually better than the other.
Many other kinds of detectors exist that are
more expensive and often situation specific
(such as needing to protect classified documents
or computer servers).
These tend to be much more sensitive and allow
for many different levels of detection and
alarm.
The most common of these is aspiration detectors.
Photoelectric detectors use a beam of light
sent from a light-emitting diode (LED) that
is detected by a photocell.
There is a common misconception that the photocell
receives light at all times from the LED,
and when smoke gets in the way, the alarm
is triggered (similar to the way a door alarm
at convenience stores often works).
This misconception ignores one glaring problem.
It would require a large amount of smoke to
block the light from the photocell, making
it extremely insensitive.
A person would be dead from smoke inhalation
long before the detector would ever go off.
What is actually happening in the photoelectric
fire alarms is the LED sends a beam of light,
usually down a T-shaped chamber.
Sitting at the bottom of the T is the photocell.
When smoke enters the chamber, some of the
light is scattered by the particles, with
some of the rays getting sent down to the
photocell.
When this photocell detects light, it generates
an electrical current that triggers the alarm
at a certain threshold.
Once that current stops (the smoke is cleared)
the alarm will stop.
Photoelectric detectors are better at detecting
slow, smoldering, and therefore generally
smokier, fires.
Ionization detectors use ionizing radiation
from a material known as Americium-241.
Ionizing radiation is simply radiation from
substances that can free electrons from an
atom or molecule, the net result being ions
that have a specific electric charge of either
positive or negative.
The detectors use a small amount of Americium-241
contained in a small chamber.
This chamber is made up of two oppositely
charged metal plates that are kept a small
distance apart.
When the alpha particles interact with the
air in the chamber, they produce ions.
The positively charged plate attracts the
negative ions, and the negatively charged
plate attracts the positive ions.
This system creates a small electric current.
When smoke enters the chamber, the particles
attach themselves to the charged ions and
restore them back to a neutral electrical
state.
This disrupts the electric current and an
alarm is triggered.
Hot air can also change the rate at which
ionization occurs within the chamber and this
will also trigger the alarm.
Ionization detectors are much more common
than photoelectric detectors because they
are less expensive and better at detecting
smaller amounts of smoke that come from fast
flaming fires.
If you’re worried about your house having
so called “nuclear radiation” in it, don’t.
The small amount of radiation found in the
detector is practically harmless, being predominantly
alpha radiation.
This type cannot even penetrate a piece of
paper and is blocked by just several centimeters
of air.
The only danger comes from if you inhale the
particles.
So no taking apart the ionization chamber
and huffing the air in it to try to develop
superpowers.
Lung tissue damage, increasing your risk of
lung cancer, and other such health problems
may not be the superpower you were hoping
for.
Plus the superhero name “Wheezy” won’t
exactly instill fear on the hearts of evil
doers the world over.
The differing strengths of these two main
types of sensors has led to the creation of
detectors that employ both types of systems.
This allows for the rapid detection of both
small smoldering fires, and fast moving ones.
The less common Aspirating smoke detectors
use a fan to draw in air from the surrounding
environment; next, a system of filtering,
sensing, and analyzing the air sample is employed.
Depending on the environment needing protection,
this system can be as sensitive (some as much
as 1,000 times as much as a standard photoelectric
or ionization detector) or advanced as the
situation requires.
Should the system detect any type of negative
environment, such as very small amounts of
smoke, small changes in temperature, or flickering
light (as from a flame) it can notify appropriate
personnel in many different ways.
Multiple levels of warning can trigger different
responses depending on the stage of the fire,
from simply notifying personnel of a pending
problem to communicating with a fire alarm
control panel to adjust air conditioning or
release different types of fire suppressing
agents, or all of the above.
Bonus Facts:
• Americium-241 is a man-made metal discovered
by Glenn Seaborg in 1944.
It is produced when plutonium atoms absorb
neutrons in nuclear reactors.
It has a half-life of 432 years.
• The first detection system that had the
ability to sense smoke was created by Greinacher
from Berne in 1922.
The first Underwriters laboratory listing
for a smoke detection device was obtained
by Walter Kidde in 1929 and was used to release
a total flooding CO2 system for shipboard
uses.
• The first ionization chamber for the purposes
of detecting smoke was inadvertently discovered
by Walter Jaeger in the 1930s while he was
attempting to develop a poison gas detector.
In the early 1940s, Jaeger and Meili got together
and created the first addition of an ionization
detector that we use today.
This first attempt used an enormous power
supply and required a 220v system.
It wasn’t until the 1960s that Americium-241
was used, requiring much less voltage.
In 1964, First Alert was able to develop a
24v ionization detector.
The widespread use of smoke detectors in households
wasn’t feasible until a year later when
Duane Pearsall and Stanley Peterson created
a single station photoelectric detector that
was powered by a battery.
• 96% of all homes in the US have at least
one smoke alarm; 75% have one that actually
works.
About 66% of deaths from home fires were the
result of homes that had no working smoke
detector.
Smoke alarms that fail are usually the result
of disconnected or dead batteries, the latter
of which comprises 25% of all smoke alarm
failures.
As such, the NFPA recommends that you check
your smoke detector and change out the batteries
twice a year.
For those who live in areas that have day-light
saving time, it is recommended that you do
this when you change your clocks.